Some people think
having a busy calendar
shows how important they are.
Not true.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Whether you're a teacher or
a leader or a small business
owner, after you
take this class,
you will emerge a better
thinker, a better listener,
a better analyzer of problems.
In this class, I teach you: how
did I motivate an organization?
How did I set a direction?
How did I make sure the
company stayed successful
over multiple years?
You've got to understand
how any decision made
at the top translates all the
way down to the frontline.
And that's what makes you an
effective and efficient leader.
I'm Indra Nooyi, and
this is MasterClass.